merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre
d'avoir répondu à cette invitation parmi
les nombreuses responsabilités
ministérielles que vous allez exercer
tout au long de votre engagement dans la
vie publique vous avez notamment été en
charge du ministère des transports de
l'équipement du tourisme et de la mer
dans le gouvernement de Dominique de
Villepin entre 2005 et 2006 vous
succédez dans cette salle Anne-Marie
Idrac était présidente d'ailleurs de la
SNCF pendant une partie du temps vous
avez été ministre des transports entre
2006 et 2007
vous allez également
occupé ce ministère de l'équipement et
des transports à un moment où la
stratégie européenne à travers le
premier puis le second paquet
ferroviaire de libéralisation du frais
de ferroviaire se déployer avec les
premiers exemples emblématiques
d'entreprises parfois française qui
recouraient à la concurrence pour le
fret ferroviaire et notamment dans les
premiers exemples emblématiques le cas
de Danone qui a été une des premières
entreprises françaises à travailler
travailler avec des opérateurs
alternatifs dans le fret sur le ministre
à travers l'intervention que vous
pourrez partager avec nous dans quelques
minutes ce que nous attendons c'est
d'abord de d'avoir des éléments sur la
manière dont le sujet du développement
du frais de ferroviaire était identifié
ou pas comme un sujet stratégique au
sein de la politique transport dans le
gouvernement auquel vous avez appartenu
la mesure auquel dans laquelle vous
pouviez estimer que Fred SNCF se dotait
d'une véritable stratégie à l'échelle
européenne au moment où vous étiez en
responsabilité mais également les échos
dans l'entreprise déjà de la situation
du frais de ferroviaire et de se déclin
de la part modale qui était engagée
depuis la fin des années 60 puisque la
régression du frais de ferroviaire on
l'a dit à de nombreuses reprises ici et
avec des intervenants de qualité à
chaque fois cette se déclin de la part
modale était engagée depuis très
longtemps et bien les réformes qui sont
intervenues dans les années 2000
monsieur le ministre votre témoignage
sera donc précieux sur les débuts de
l'ouverture effective du frais de
ferroviaire à la concurrence et je vous
rappelle mais vous le savez puisque vous
avez siéger longtemps à l'Assemblée
nationale et que vous y êtes beaucoup
engagé que cette audition est bien sûr
ouverte à la presse les retransmise en
direct sur le site de l'Assemblée
nationale je vous laisserai la parole je
le disais pour une intervention
liminaire d'une dizaine de minutes puis
nous poursivons ces échanges sous la
forme de questions et de réponse
auparavant je vous rappelle que
l'article 6 de l'ordonnance du 17
novembre 1958 relative au fonctionnement
des assemblées parlementaires imposent
aux personnes auditionnées par une
commission d'enquête de prêter le
serment de dire toute la vérité rien que
la vérité vous le savez monsieur le
ministre j'imagine que vous avez
appartenu à plusieurs commissions
d'enquête dans cette maison je vous
invite donc à lever la main droite et à
dire je jure
je vous remercie vous avez donc la
parole monsieur le ministre
voilà monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les députés merci de
m'accueillir
c'est loin tout de même en termes de
mémoire humaine je veux dire
donc
soyez indulgent sur
sur ma capacité à
restituer ce qui pouvait être l'ambiance
2005 2007 jusqu'à la présidentielle de
2007 et c'est à la fin de l'exercice de
mes fonctions qui effectivement
malaminrac a été nommé à la tête de la
SNCF
alors
l'époque était assez sensiblement
différente à ce qu'on peut percevoir
aujourd'hui en termes de ferroviaire on
était dans la
l'accélération du programme TGV
qui ensuite a eu de très mauvaise presse
et puis qui aujourd'hui recommencer à
être mieux perçu mais
nous étions très mobilisé là-dessus avec
des enquêtes publiques difficiles
c'était la deuxième tranche de Paris
Strasbourg c'était le début de
Paris-Bordeaux
c'était les interrogations sur le
contournement de Montpellier la ligne
espagnole et donc
une comment dire
une vision positive dynamique
presque agressive mais au bon sens du
terme de
du ferroviaire c'est à dire qu'on y
croit on y va on met de l'argent et on
lance des appels d'offres les grands du
BTP se lancent dans l'aventure enfin
voilà donc il y avait ce côté très très
positif bon
et puis il y avait effectivement le fret
et là bon
l'ambiance était morose parce qu'on
voulait bien les chiffres
on avait le sentiment de pas avoir les
réponses en tout cas au niveau
ministériel on les avait pas dans
l'entreprise des dirigeants de l'époque
essayer de trouver des solutions alors
on s'est mobilisé sur un certain nombre
de sujets assez précis je m'en souviens
par exemple des autoroutes ferroviaires
avec
Perpignan Luxembourg ou
l'idée c'était vous le savez mieux que
personne c'était de mettre les camions
sur les trains bon
là on a on a travaillé là dessus il y
avait aussi bien sûr le projet par le
Mont-Cenis sur les Alpes il y avait
l'esquisse d'un projet sur l'Atlantique
avec d'ailleurs j'ai entendu la fin de
l'intervention de Madame midrac tout à
l'heure en arrivant avec justement les
les goulets d'étranglement la région
lyonnaise en particulier où j'avais été
amené à faire des choix qui ont
d'ailleurs été je crois remis en cause
après mon départ mais ça c'est la vie
politique c'était l'affaire ni
Montpellier et là on avait effectivement
des difficultés importantes et puis
c'est qu'il y avait aussi le grand
projet qui a été évoqué tout à l'heure à
la fin de l'audition de Madame midrac
sur sur les Alpes avec nos amis italiens
et
bon ce projet qui est toujours
en discussion et en début de réalisation
il y avait aussi
l'idée de
du frais de ferroviaire
en utilisant les rapides en utilisant
les lignes TGV la nuit alors
vous imaginez
les inquiétudes qui ont pu s'exprimer
quand on a quand cette idée est sortie
je crois pas d'ailleurs qu'elle est
beaucoup prospiré
mais c'était
[Musique]
une idée de d'améliorer le qualitatif du
fret c'est-à-dire en disant on propose
certains clients
plus de rapidité plus d'efficacité pour
ça on peut utiliser les lignes TGV avec
des transs spéciaux il y avait aussi
l'esquisse de mise en place d'opérateurs
ferroviaires de proximité on pensait
qu'il y avait là peut-être
une technique pour j'irai rassembler des
capacités de de transport par le fer en
partant de en partant de la proximité en
partant éventuellement même de des
collectivités locales alors
en vous disant cela je vous dis en même
temps
l'ouverture à la concurrence c'était pas
tellement notre sujet en fait à ce
moment-là
il y avait la question de l'ouverture à
la concurrence des
des voyageurs puisque le troisième
paquet c'est effectivement 2007 et je me
souviens
presque physique presque physiquement de
conversation que j'ai pu avoir avec les
leaders des organisations syndicales à
ce moment-là qui est bon qui
s'interrogeait et qui s'inquiétait mais
sur le fret notre problème c'était
plutôt
l'effondrement du trafic
et le fait qu'il semblait qu'il n'y ait
pas de solution alors que pourtant on
avait mis en place des dispositifs de
transfert d'investissement en direction
du ferroviaire c'était la fille qui
fonctionnait dont on avait trouvé des
nouveaux financements et donc une
volonté de rééquilibrer les choses mais
sans doute avec avec beaucoup de
difficultés voilà ce que je voulais vous
dire de bonne manière luminaire pour
vous resituer un peu les choses dans un
contexte qui était évidemment très
différente celui d'aujourd'hui et
autant la question de l'ouverture à la
concurrence du frais de
du trafic voyageur était un débat
politique
fort difficile parfois et qui avait
abouti un certain nombre de d'éléments
autant sur le fret ferroviaire la
question était plutôt
comment faire en sorte que
l'équipe Fred de la SNCF retrouve de la
capacité et retrouve de la demande
merci merci Monsieur le Ministre une
question avant de céder tout de suite la
parole aux collègues
la période ça a été notamment rappelé
par Patrick Janet ancien président PDG
de SNCF réseau hier la période pendant
laquelle vous avez exercé vos
responsabilités d'une période qui a été
marquée par une remontée progressive
jusqu'à aujourd'hui des investissements
dans le les infrastructures ferroviaires
le mouvement et ça a été bien identifié
par beaucoup de chercheurs à commencer
en 2003 après le rapport de l'Institut
politique de Lausanne sur l'état de
notre réseau ferroviaire est-ce que dans
ces investissements sur les
infrastructures ferroviaires vous
estimez où vous gardez souvenir que la
volonté de développer le fret dans
l'arbitrage parce que l'argent public
est rare et il était déjà est-ce que
vous avez le sentiment que dans la
priorisation de ces investissements la
volonté de développer le frais de
ferroviaire a été suffisamment prise en
compte
c'est toujours difficile parce que après
coup on voit les choses un peu
différemment de quand on est sur le dans
l'actualité comme je vous le rappelais
tout à l'heure on a c'était une période
où on a beaucoup investi sur les trains
grandes vitesses et à la suite du
rapport de Lausanne de nos amis suisses
rapport qui moi m'avait brigment
inquiété en tant responsable politique
parce qu'il
expliquait qu'il y avait des risques il
y avait des problèmes on était obligé de
ralentir des vitesses etc bon et donc on
a commencé à mettre le paquet sur cette
aspect sécurité du réseau
très honnêtement là vous faites appel à
des souvenirs avec
l'incertitude humaine mais on n'était
pas spécifiquement
dans ces
doubles priorités qui étaient déjà
considérable on n'était pas
spécifiquement en alerte sur le les
contraintes particulières au frais au
frais de ferroviaire
ce qui est ce qui est certain ce qu'on a
entendu à plusieurs reprises avec
certains de nos intervenants c'était que
dans le regard qui était jeté sur le
sujet ferroviaire au sens large que soit
ferroviaire voyageur ou fret la question
de l'aménagement du territoire était
toujours regardé en premier et c'est
vrai que le sujet de la transition
écologique dans le regard qu'on pouvait
jeter sur le mode de transport lourd
notamment sur pour le frais de
ferroviaire était moins important que du
kiné aujourd'hui ça c'est quelque chose
qui qui a été mise en avant de très
nombreuses reprises monsieur le
rapporteur je vous donne la parole
merci merci
le ministre
vous êtes responsabilités de 2005 à 2016
c'est à dire les
toutes premières années où
la France
doit assumer c'est
responsabilité ces engagements vis-à-vis
de la Commission européenne après que la
Commission européenne est autorisée
l'aide d'un milliard 5 SNCF
lorsque l'on lit
la raccord de la Commission européenne
motivée de 2005
[Musique]
à plusieurs reprises dans les attendus
écrits de cet accord
les autorités françaises s'engagent
à présenter un certain nombre de pièces
qui doivent témoigner
du bon déroulement du plan de
restructuration
qui
accompagnait l'accord de précéder et
accompagner avec le plan Véron puis le
plan marenbau le plan de restructuration
grosso modo qui sait développer de 2003
à 2008
les autorités françaises notamment de
devait présenter annuellement un rapport
à la commission permettant un Commission
européenne permettant de contrôler le
bon déroulement du plan de
restructuration
les commissions de la Commission
européenne devait avoir les moyens de
contrôler durablement
l'étanchéité des comptes entre
l'activité prête et l'activité voyageurs
et notamment s'assurer des que les
relations financières
se feraient durablement sur des bases
commerciales
les autorités françaises étaient
engagées à procéder à un audit
indépendant durant toute la période de
restructuration et on transmettre les
conclusions à la Commission
européenne et la Commission européenne
globalement
est textuellement dans l'accord veillera
au respect de la mise en oeuvre du plan
de restructuration donc qui couvre une
période de votre responsabilité entre
2005 et 2007 pourriez-vous s'il vous
plaît
témoigner de bien de vous rapport de
rapport du ministère dans la période où
vous étiez en responsabilité avec la
Commission européenne sur la base des
engagements je dirais contractuels pris
entre la France comme dit la le texte de
la croix entre la France et la
Commission européenne donc l'ensemble
c'est de ces dispositions de suivi de
l'accord de 2005
bon monsieur le reporter très
honnêtement j'en ai absolument pas le
souvenir aujourd'hui
je peux pas j'imagine que c'est quelque
chose qui s'est déroulé normalement mais
je n'en ai pas le souvenir aujourd'hui
j'ai commencé tout à l'heure en
soulignant la distance qui nous sépare
de cette période tout de même bientôt 20
ans
Président si
questionne en l'occurrence c'est que
bien évidemment dans la commission
d'enquête qui
qui est en cours à l'échelle européenne
la période ciblée à partir de laquelle
les aides illicitent
auraient été
organisé
se situe à partir de 2007 et à plusieurs
reprises
Commission européenne dans son argument
dans son argumentaire indique
ne pas avoir été
véritablement saisie comme prévu par le
texte de l'accord des rendus du suivi
notamment du plan de restructuration
2003-2008
de la part des autorités françaises donc
je comprends fort bien monsieur le
ministre que les choses
et
et quelques années
mais je me permettais d'insister sur
le rapport quel qu'il soit d'ailleurs
au delà des engagements réciproques que
vous auriez pu avoir avec la Commission
européenne durant le temps de votre
fonction
non j'ai rien à ajouter là-dessus
est-ce qu'il y a des questions de la
part de nos collègues
vous avez dit ambiance morose dans le
fret tout est concentré à l'époque vous
êtes à faire sur l'investissement le
développement du TGV finalement
qu'on
utilise aujourd'hui pour les pour les
voyageurs et le seul problème est
fondament du trafic donc ce contexte là
le gouvernement
vous au niveau du ministère de transport
dans vos rapports avec les SNCF
vous avez un souvenir de de
stratégie à partager pour
pour sauver le bébé fret ou l'abandonner
ou remettre de remettre un peu d'argent
dans le moteur ou que de la subvention
ou de l'investissement un petit peu
quels étaient les instructions que le
gouvernement pouvait donner à SNCF pour
pour ce sujet du frais de ferroviaire
merci de cette question
instruction c'est pas tout à fait le mot
enfin
le président de la SNCF pendant la
quasi-totalité de de
mes fonctions de ministre c'était Louis
Gallois bon chacun connaît le personnage
bon je veux dire on avait en plus petite
histoire nous étions de la même année de
la même école donc on se connaissait
bien j'avais une immense confiance en
lui et beaucoup de respect pour lui je
sais qu'il a réfléchi avec son équipe à
ce moment-là il réfléchissait avec son
équipe à
d'éventuelles évolutions structurelles
alors il faudrait sans doute lui poser à
lui la question mais je sais qu'à
l'époque on en avait discuté ensemble
moi je lui avais dit soyons prudents
parce que
j'avais la responsabilité politique
dans le domaine des transports nous
étions quand même
dans une période tendue contenu de la
l'ouverture à la concurrence du trafic
voyageur il y avait des grandes
manifestations à Bruxelles à Paris moi
je dialoguais autant que je le pouvais
et
d'assez bonne condition d'ailleurs avec
les leaders syndicaux de la SNCF mais
comment vous dire
je vais parler un peu franchement on
n'avait pas envie d'en remettre non plus
bon
c'était pas de provoquer la pagaille
donc
moi je vais à l'époque évoquer avec lui
Gallois dire attendez bon soyons prudent
enfin bon voilà c'est c'est ce contexte
là aujourd'hui l'idée de concurrence
l'ouverture au trafic etc c'est passé
bon mais
souvenons-nous c'était c'était plus que
ça même et ce que je dis pour la France
c'était et valable aussi pour
l'Allemagne j'en discutais avec mes
collègues également à l'époque
il faut savoir évoluer aussi mais on
était dans ce contexte politique donc on
savait bien que dans le sur le fric il y
avait un problème que sans doute la SNCF
historiquement avait peut-être pas
consacré toute l'énergie toute
l'imagination créatrice nécessaire pour
essayer de d'être plus à l'écoute de sa
clientèle potentielle
c'est vrai qu'on était dans la période
d'accélération du TGV de l'heure du
problème de la sécurisation de des
réseaux comment l'évoquait tout à
l'heure donc c'était peut-être pas
suffisamment prioritaire
quand on quand on regarde posteriori
maintenant
oui on a une question de Monsieur
Mathieu marteau monsieur le député vous
avez la parole
pardon
monsieur le ministre
à l'époque vous pensez que la
libéralisation du marché intérieur elle
est dynamiser le frais de ferroviaire
est-ce que vous étiez conscient donc de
l'État l'État à l'époque des voix
ferroviaires ne permettait pas donc de
rendre un service de qualité et que cet
état des voies n'était plutôt un
problème pour l'ouverture à la
concurrence
oui on l'a évoqué tout à l'heure à la
suite du rapport qui avait été
réalisé par nos amis de Lausanne bon on
savait qu'il y avait des difficultés
dans un certain endroit il y avait aussi
des goulets d'étranglement je les ai
évoqué tout à l'heure et il y avait
nécessité de d'augmenter
l'investissement
sur sur
les infrastructures en particulier pour
avoir une meilleure offre en matière de
fret et c'est sûr on en était conscient
de ça
bien merci beaucoup est-ce qu'il y a oui
monsieur le rapporteur vous souhaitiez
reprendre la parole
c'est pas grave
si le ministre oui je reprends parce que
votre votre témoignage
résonne un peu comme celui de votre
collègue le ministre Goulard hier et qui
a été
auditionné qui nous disait pendant les
mêmes termes mais
voilà question de la libéralisation
c'était pas un sujet pour nous à
l'époque voilà
[Musique]
vous avez le sentiment qui avait pas de
il y avait pas de
il y avait pas d'éléments de réponse
c'était mon rose dans le fret mais il y
avait pas d'éléments de réponse ce que
vous qui nous était tout ça pour vous
pour vous demander si vous avez pas le
sentiment parce qu'on nous a aussi
indiqué une
des difficultés dans les rapports entre
RF donc mis en place 197 et la SNCF
ce que vous avez ce que vous avez pas le
sentiment y compris assez tardivement on
arrive là en 2005 2007 que
les directions
des entités ferroviaires que ce soit RFF
que ce soit donc la SNCF est frette
également
on parle on pas vraiment aidé les
politiques
ont pas vraiment aidé les politiques
dans
la prise en compte du
du lourd handicap qui s'accumulait sur
l'activité
Fred dans notre pays ce que vous avez
pas le sentiment que comme vous le
disiez tout à l'heure
le focus porté sur
le TGV Francis le voyageur
a pas quand même
considérablement pesé
auprès des politiques
empêchant ainsi des décisions peut-être
un peu plus mature en la matière
ce que finalement qu'on
interroge monsieur Goulard peut-être
vous-même
on est quand même dans des plans de
restructuration lourdes entre 2003 et 2
et 2008 l'environ plan marins Rambaud
mais on n'a pas le sentiment
où je me trompe que ces plantes
restructuration
ait été comme on dirait à la main du
politique
vous avez sans doute un peu un peu
raison je pense que
je voulais l'ensemble du système
ferroviaire
malgré les réformes de 97
étaient restés très unitaire finalement
et j'ajouterai volontiers que
sans
suggérer de ma liste mais que
avec aussi les directions du ministère
je veux dire c'est le même monde et
c'est pas une critique que je formule
c'est un constat que je fais avec des
gens avec des femmes et des hommes de
très grande qualité des ingénieurs
absolument remarquables mais
cet univers n'a pas encore intégré la
libéralisation
la séparation du réseau et du bien sûr
juridiquement tout ça a été fait mais on
sent bien que ça reste la même maison
d'ailleurs
ce qui s'est passé en Allemagne a montré
que je trouve que les Allemands sont en
partie revenus en arrière bon tout ça
est pas simple qu'à partir du moment où
on part d'une très grande société
nationale qui depuis un siècle etc ce
qui était le cas aussi chez nos voisins
allemands bon c'est pas très facile de
de changer de d'univers alors
est-ce qu'il y avait une opacité par
rapport au
monde politique je ne le crois pas parce
que c'est un monde de loyauté c'est un
monde d'ingénieur c'est un monde de gens
qui respectent les institutions et moi
j'ai jamais eu de difficultés
particulières et
je crois pas que que mes collègues ont
eu spécialement simplement on est très
vite dans des sujets très techniques
très complexes et il est pas si facile
que ça pour un politique d'aller dans le
dialogue à un niveau suffisamment précis
peut-être pour faire davantage bouger
les choses voilà ce que l'analyse que je
ferai volontiers
parce que
parce que si il faut il faut vraiment
beaucoup maîtriser ces sujets pour
pouvoir entrer dans une
[Musique]
discussion un peu constructive
oui je on se fait écho est-ce que disait
et donner tout de suite la parole à
Monsieur le Rapporteur à ce qu'il disait
implicitement en parlant du portage
politique des différents plans de
relance du fret
question un peu faciles monsieur le
ministre je vous d'accord
diriez-vous que dans la manière
d'investir le sujet du ferroviaire au
sens large et du frais de ferroviaire en
particulier il y avait une crainte de
rallumer des conflits qui avaient que la
France avait connu en 1995 il y a eu
certes des grèves depuis mais des
conflits qui avaient sans doute
profondément marqué certains des
dirigeants de la France qui l'était
toujours entre
2005 et 2007 je pense au secrétaire
général de l'isée de l'époque au
président de la République est-ce que
pour vous cette idée que quand on
touchait au ferroviaire il y avait un
risque de conflit social très étendu ça
expliquer peut-être en partie le
sentiment d'un portage de politique
publique qui était moins moins fort
qu'il n'aurait pu l'être ou qu'il ne l'a
été par la suite
peut-être peut-être
j'en suis pas absolument sûr moi j'ai en
1995 j'étais à partir du mois de
novembre 19 fonctions publiques donc
j'ai quelques souvenirs de la période
j'ai appris beaucoup d'ailleurs dans ce
ministère et ce que j'y avais appris
mais d'ailleurs beaucoup aidé lorsque je
suis devenu ministre des Transports
parce que j'avais qu'une certaine
pratique du dialogue syndicale y compris
dans un esprit parfois très amical alors
[Musique]
pour être précis
95 97 au ministère des Transports
l'Élysée ne m'a jamais rien demandé
en termes de
m'a pas dit calmos nous casse pas les
pieds avec je parle comme ça parce que
c'est la façon dont le président de
chaque parlait assez ministres nous
casse pas les pieds avec avec tes
histoires non Dieu sait ça m'est arrivé
dans d'autres postes ministériels mais
pendant celui-là
donc il y avait pas il y avait pas ce
traumatisme mais nous nous le portions
peut-être et
[Musique]
je veux dire la transformation de la
Société nationale des chemins de fer
de de société monopolistique avec sa
culture avec son système de de valeur
etc enfin toute chose que quand on
connaît un peu la SNCF on touche du
doigt enfin c'est une réalité alors il y
a des côtés négatifs bien sûr c'est un
peu routinier tout ça mais mais c'est
quand même des gens qui pour l'essentiel
ont le sentiment de faire partie d'une
grande maison voilà pour dire les choses
façon simple et donc moi mon souci à
l'époque c'était effectivement de faire
bouger cette maison mais d'essayer de
garder ça parce que ça ça a de la valeur
à tout point de vue donc
quand je répondais à Monsieur le Député
tout à l'heure je veux dire on voulait
pas non plus en rajouter c'est vrai
parce qu'on avait Bruxelles qui nous
tenait avec l'ouverture à la concurrence
des voyageurs on était obligé d'y aller
parce que on avait déjà utilisé tous les
délais
qu'on pouvait et donc on n'avait pas
envie de faire flamber la maison c'est
sûr
si un exercice toujours oui je me
permets de continuer dans cette dans
cette veine parce que j'ai entendu votre
votre
identification
comme gaulliste social finalement vous
aviez une belle maison qui vous voilà
une belle maison intégrée et
et quand je vous ai posé la question
tout à l'heure de savoir en gros
la question c'était laquelle c'était
vis-à-vis de vous est-ce qu'on vous
apporte excusez-moi de l'expression mais
en qui est des choses
[Musique]
au travers de direction
technocratique je faisais référence
direction technocratique parce que
un expert du ferroviaire dit que dans
les années 97 2000 on est passé dans le
ferroviaire de et vous disiez que ces
ingénieurs étaient l'honnêteté même dans
votre propos on était passé de
l'ingénieur à l'économiste
et que finalement les équipes
dirigeantes
c'était elle
faite très rapidement à l'idée de cette
mise en œuvre de la libéralisation de la
concurrence etc donc
mon propos que j'essaye de de
déployer c'est
le savoir si vous n'avez pas
effectivement indépendamment de du bien
entendu d'un point de vue politique
voilà qu'on n'est pas d'en rajouter
inutilement mais
est-ce que vous pourriez conclure
à l'idée
que en fait
cette restructuration a été une
restructuration donc sur le long terme
près de 5 ans qui a été
échappé disons le clairement ou
politique
a été conduite
voire vous l'avez dit vous-même
vis-à-vis de politique qui appréciait
cette maison cette grande maison de la
SNCF et bien comme vous là on vous l'a
fait passer quoi
parce que quand même entre entre 2003 et
2008 alors on parle bien sûr de
l'opérateur historique mais c'est un
affaiblissement considérable à travers
des plans Véron et marabouts sans pour
autant que le rétablissement de la
rentabilité telle que on peut
l'envisager dans un dans une logique
libérale n'a été restauré
le trafic continue de dégringoler
c'est aussi le marché et qui a décidé je
veux dire
alors les plans en question ils ont ils
ont constaté ou anticipé
les restructurations nécessaires mais
c'est le client qui était pas au
rendez-vous il faut pas oublier ça je
pense que il y a eu pendant les mêmes
années une transformation assez profonde
de notre système économique pour dire
les choses simples les stocks sont
maintenant sur les routes ils sont pas
dans les usines
bon ça s'est passé à peu près à ces
moments-là et c'est vrai que
cette transformation de la logistique
le chemin de fer a pas été au
rendez-vous
alors est-ce qu'il aurait pu y être moi
je ne sais pas je n'ai pas la réponse
technique et
est-ce que c'était possible en tout cas
c'est un boratage quoi parce que au
moment où l'économie fait que
la logistique explose j'étais merde
Chalon-sur-Saône pendant 20 ans et j'ai
développé avec mes concitoyens toute une
série d'activités puisqu'on avait la
chance d'être sur l'axe son rôle et
l'emploi logistique
assez énormément développé donc j'ai
vécu vraiment de près cette
transformation de notre économie et
c'est vrai que le ferroviaire n'en a pas
profité du tout
est-ce que c'était trop compliqué compte
tenu des ruptures de charge est-ce que
le principe même de cette transformation
économique de la logistique moderne qui
fait que le stock est sur la route
est-ce que ça n'implique pas qu'on va
jusqu'au bout
moi je ne sais pas je sais pas
suffisamment technicien de ces sujets
mais j'observe que on a raté le coche là
pour le coup il y avait un potentiel
considérable que les transporteurs
routiers ont complètement capté
bien ce qu'il y a d'autres questions
très bien monsieur le ministre merci
beaucoup d'avoir répondu à notre
audition on termine donc là pour ce qui
est des auditions d'aujourd'hui et
reprendre nos travaux demain matin merci